usually I don't think notation and math
matters that much don't get me wrong I
enjoy a bad notation rant as much as the
next guy and there are clearly a few
simple changes to our conventions that
could speed up learning for math
students everywhere but at the end of
the day notation good or bad it's just
not the point of math even the most
carefully designed symbols and syntax
will fail to capture the underlying
visual that constitutes understanding so
I figured it's better to just spend time
focusing on that underlying essence and
let the symbols just be what they are in
peace but that said when unintuitive
notation actively stalls the gears of
learning my disposition on the matter
hardens up a little bit in particular
I'm thinking of one threesome of syntax
which when you stop and think about it
is an egregious source of friction in
math education everywhere if you take
the fact that 2 multiplied by itself 3
times equals 8 for example we have 3
separate ways to explain that
relationship 2 cubed equals 8 with a
superscript the cube root of 8 is 2 with
a spangly radical symbol and the log
base 2 of 8 equals 3 which we write
using the word log itself what the hell
do these 3 ways of writing the same fact
have to do with each other making up
syntax for a concept is fine but don't
do it in 3 completely different ways for
the same concept and for students to
learn every rule about that concept
three separate times it's like it's a
different language this way of writing
things isn't just counter intuitive it's
counter mathematical since rather than
making seemingly different facts look
the same which is what math should do it
takes 3 facts which should obviously be
the same and makes them look
artificially different just think about
how confusing logarithms were the first
time that you learned about them
this is of course a known issue and the
Internet has no shortage of people
raising the same concern with
suggestions for a better notation but
recently I stumbled across a math
exchange post with a suggestion so
lovely and so symmetrical so utterly
reasonable that I just have to share it
for a relationship like two cubed equals
eight take a triangle and write two in
the lower left three on the top and
eight on the lower right to express the
operation two cubed remove that bottom
right corner the symbol as a whole
represents the value that should go in
the missing corner to Express log base
two of eight which is asking the
question two to the what equals eight
remove the top number the symbol as a
whole represents the value that should
go in the missing corner to express the
cube root of 8 which is saying what
number to the third power equals eight
remove the bottom left corner the symbol
as a whole represents the value that
should go in the missing corner in other
words all three operations are
completely symmetrically represented
this triangle deserves a name and a
friend of mine at Khan Academy decided
that we should call it the triangle of
power the definition alone is mildly
pleasing but where it gets fun is when
you see how much smoother all of the
different operations become in our
current notation there are six different
ways to express the various inverse
operations
most of these are memorized as separate
entities some are rarely even talked
about and there's no discernible pattern
even though all of them describe the
same basic idea but students still have
to spend six times the effort to
memorize each one are six times more
likely to make a mistake
and have six separate opportunities to
decide math is dumb and boring and
conducive to failure and why I don't
know just go study yard instead
with a triangle of power all these
operations follow the same pattern
our brains are really good at picking up
on patterns like this and you can much
more easily imagine a smooth mental
image associated with the property
there's even kind of an aesthetic
pleasure to this and who knows maybe
more of the artistically inclined
students would look favorably upon math
long enough to see just how valuable
their intuitions really are in the
science let's take another property like
the idea that 8 to the X times a to the
y equals a to the X plus y the
corresponding fact for logarithms is
that log of x times y equals log of X
plus log of Y when you write this with
the triangle of power it's a little
easier to see that both of these
expressions are really saying the same
thing remember the symbol as a whole
represents the number at the missing
corner so the top expression is saying
that when you multiply two numbers that
belong in the bottom right of the
triangle it corresponds with adding the
numbers that belong to the top but
that's also what the lower expression is
saying when you multiply the numbers at
the bottom right it corresponds with
adding numbers that belong to the top
to help students with this you could
draw inside of the triangle saying that
when the lower-left is constant the
numbers at the top like to add while the
bottom right numbers like to multiply
what about when a different corner stays
constant like the top well in this case
you'd write a multiplication sign in
both the bottom corners because with
exponents and radicals multiplication
turns into multiplication the natural
question that a student might ask from
here is if there's an analogous rule for
when the lower right stays constant
there is you have to introduce a new
operation which for the sake of this
video I'll call a plus where a a plus B
equals 1 over 1 over a plus 1 over B
this is not actually a ridiculous thing
to introduce since it comes up in
physics all the time like when you're
computing parallel resistance with that
symbol you could say that when the
lower-right number stays constant the
top number is like to get o+ together
and the bottom-left number is like to
get multiplied
this is actually a really nice
connection between logarithms and roots
and the never gets discussed probably
because the notation isn't really
conducive to asking the question I could
go on and on here showing a lot of other
properties but honestly I think the best
case I can make here is to encourage you
to explore it for yourself and notice
that just about everything involving
exponents logs of radicals becomes nicer
when you use the triangle of power by
the way I hope that it goes without
saying that in this perfect world
students wouldn't learn these operations
purely from the symbols they should
still ask why it's true and why it
doesn't follow a different pattern but
the point is that when the notation
actually reflects the math the questions
that students are most naturally asking
tend to be the ones that cut right into
the essence of what's going on the
asymmetries in the notation correspond
with actual asymmetries in the numerical
relationship a to the B equals C itself
not in the artificial asymmetries of
squiggles and words when a student asks
why the top likes to get added in one
context but oblast and another the
teacher can point out the property that
reflecting the triangle reciprocate s'
the top and then we can start addressing
where that fact comes from my sincere
hope is the students don't learn by
symbolic patterns but by substantive
reasoning and re derivation within their
own heads but the fact is most of us do
first learn things by symbolic
manipulation so when there's an
opportunity to significantly speed up
that process we should take it and if
you agree with me that the triangle of
power is clearly better than what we
have already start actually using it in
your notes to see what it feels like
spread the word and if you're a teacher
maybe start teaching this to your
students so that we can get them hooked
while they're young
you